are you in favor of universal basic
income to enable people to have time
well I'm in favor of it for a lot of
reasons I'm in favor of it because I
think you know in a rich economy nobody
should be homeless on the street
absolutely I mean absolutely not people
are homeless because of drug addiction
or mental illness we should have some
facilities to help them second I'm in
favor because as a technologist I see um
we're gonna have massive job loss I mean
it's coming it's like it it doesn't
matter yes technology creates more jobs
and there will be many new jobs that we
cannot imagine you said but in the
process of transition people are gonna
get left behind yes and we've gotta have
this for those people third if it can
give people more time to be creative
that's great yeah I think all of those
are good I think a bigger problem when
we talk about time to be creative is the
bigger danger is is not even not having
enough money to do it it's because I
know many people have lots of money have
no time to be creative it's that we
program ourselves up now because our
devices are constantly bombarding us
with very tantalizing alluring
information and entertainment and our
friends contacting us that we are always
having to respond to yeah and I
personally in order to make more time to
be creative and more time to feel sane I
turned off all my notifications I have
no notifications on my phone messages
come in but they don't pop up they don't
distract me so I will still check
Facebook I'll still check my email all
these different things but I'll do it on
my schedule yeah and that way when I'm
working every few seconds I'm not
getting dragged away because of course
in order to be creative you need
uninterrupted time and it has to be long
enough so you know the flow so you can
get into the flow and start thinking
deeply and the creativity and you can
never get into flow if you have a
constant leaps and Hudson you know a
little little red circles with numbers
in them that like our irresistible candy
to US adults right I have to I have to
eat it you know lottery machine what am
I just message me now